the glamor days of plane travel may be
long gone but now some airlines are
putting a focus back on comfort Alaska
Airlines became the nation's fifth
largest carrier after buying out Virgin
America and now it is unveiling a brand
new look with special attention to how
passengers experience a flight from
their seats the relaunch comes as
several of the biggest airlines are also
investing millions on their cabins Kris
Van Cleave takes us aboard for a look at
alaska's makeover alaska flight 95/65 is
making a big loop around California's
Bay Area but it's less about the
destination today and more about the
ride were with dozens of frequent fliers
like Jody Jenice who Alaska is hoping to
impress with its fresh new cabin Alaska
is investing tens of millions to address
a huge challenge melding Virgin
America's trendy vibe with the more
traditional Alaska in a way that makes
loyalists happy and they come up with
the scenic design an airline president
been minute kuchi the Virgin was a bit
like a flying dance club yeah
and Alaska was not yeah and their
customers at virgin and the customers
Alaska liked what they had getting it
just right so everyone's happy it has to
be a challenge we just needed to evolve
evolve to something that's a little more
stylish a little more modern so we
needed to have something that really
resonated with with with passengers the
Virgin Fleet is getting this new look
outside but to go from the old interior
to this on an Airbus a321 neo takes 45
people 18 days two years of work went
into picking the right welcoming cabin
colors the mood lighting virgin is known
for gets a new blue hue designed to calm
and complement fliers circadian rhythm
cutting jetlag they've upped the number
of seats in first class and thinner
seats allow more an economy while
keeping legroom about the same the only
people who lost some space were persons
first I went from a 55 to a 40 but we
put more seats it's usually not how that
works we want to make sure people flying
in the main
having feel good about their experience
the new seats were designed by BMWs
design works and feature hand-cut memory
foam to feel a bit like a luxury car you
know when people hear BMW right they
think about a car right the seat is
obviously taking cues from the
automotive seat in its performance in
the cushioning sort of the lumbar
support but it was this custom clip on
the seat back for a tablet or phone in
economy that got people talking and in
premium economy an added surprise I know
it doesn't sound like a big deal
redesigning a tray table but look
there's a cup holder so your drink isn't
going anywhere you can put your tablet
or phone up here to watch something it's
ergonomically better for you and there's
still room for your laptop and there are
two chargers so I'm charging my phone
can charge my laptop work and watch this
is really a make-or-break move for
Alaska it's critical for their future
success airline analyst Henry Hart de
belt says people are motivated by the
cabin experience 15% of Flyers
satisfaction comes just from the seat if
Alaska doesn't do this right people
aren't going to choose the airline
they'll fly with other airlines that
either have cheaper fares more flights
or both United is expanding first-class
on several aircraft including adding it
to 50-seat regional jets and competitor
JetBlue is in the midst of updating its
fleet with bigger seat back TVs new
lighting and new seats aimed at giving
people more room at knee level for
former Virgin Flyer Michael Thomas
alaska's cup holder sold it
and it's gonna be drilling a small
innovation that could have a big impact
as Alaska tries to climb higher than
ever for CBS this morning Saturday Kris
Van Cleave San Francisco I like my
whiskey to be I'll take my coffee that
way I like the charger I can put my
mirror up and then I can curl my hair
don't you curl your hair next either one
of you out of flight the way you talk